how are you doing hi steve good how are
you
i am doing excellent there was a cat on
my lap and now he is gone oh
he might appear again
honestly you never know um so i got a
bunch of questions for you um i'm going
to start with what do you um most i mean
it's a little generic but what are you
most excited for people to see in the
hawkeye series that perhaps they haven't
seen in a mcu show before
i think there's a different side of
clint that people haven't seen in any of
the avengers movies
i think that was the um
one of the reasons why i gravitated
towards doing this particular project is
showing a different side of him um i
remember when i was reading the comics
version of clinton kate in the fraction
uh run that i just love
how funny um he is and just there's this
lighter tone and we wanted to preserve
what we did with clint in the last you
know decade in the avengers movie but
wanted to bring that element into this
particular series as well because
you know the door's wide open in terms
of his backstory because you know
there's so much that we can explore um
so we thought the best person to do that
would be kate bishop and create that
dynamic that is so appealing that
everybody you know loved so much so it's
it's amazing because jeremy is so funny
um and he
was really game in terms of wanting to
put clint in situations and um
associated associate him with people
that he normally wouldn't um you know be
involved in and and what you get in the
series is what you know what that is
speaking of kate uh how aware were you
guys behind the scenes of like the fan
casting with haley um was that something
that you guys were all aware of or were
you looking at her on on your own
i think we're always you know with any
of the new roles that we have um
uh
casting them
we're always throwing names in and
talking about um everybody to see who is
who is a great fit for the character um
i
didn't tune in much in terms of um how
the fans were responding or reacting it
was really just you know trying to
figure out who the best role is and as
soon as you know haley walked in we just
knew that she
you know she was the one she exuded all
of the you know uh uh um personality
that i saw in kate from the comics that
i wanted to bring you know on screen and
um
and i feel she actually you know killed
it in in the series
oh she's fantastic and i mean i know
once people see the series they're going
to be like oh what else is she doing in
the mcu so i ask you uh do you guys have
like have you already figured out behind
the scenes her like arc if you will and
without like i know you're not going to
share it with me but i'm just curious if
you guys have figured it out
well i can't say you know much about it
uh
because i think our focus really is
making sure that we land kate wright in
the series like she has got to work
um in in introducing her into the mcu
for a potential future right um so i
think the focus um for for the few years
that i i have on this particular project
was making sure that you know kate was
gonna come off um in in the way that we
wanted her to and in a way that fits
within the mcu and with clint barton so
that has been the focus and we'll see
from there if if you know what the
future holds
i like the evade but yeah you did it
mission accomplished you know um did you
guys ever decide uh or did you ever
discuss doing more or less than six
episodes or how does that number sort of
get figured out is it a budgetary thing
is it like we're writing and we figured
out we have six it's like six story you
know what i mean yeah yeah we you know
what the great thing about um
doing these series is that there isn't
really a set amount of episode um that
is put upon us it's really trying to
figure out the story right what is the
most important thing is let's lay out
the groundworks with the story um with
these characters and then um and then if
it happens to be you know five or six or
seven or or nine um like some of the
other episodes i think six has normally
or or have been sort of the range um
that we're after but there is
flexibility in that we're not you know
required to say it absolutely has to be
six episodes the most important thing is
let's make sure that we tell the right
story first well i guess my question is
did it ever come close to being another
number than six
we initially um when we were talking
about the series you know the eight
episodes floated around um and then as
we were you know continuing developing
it um it sort of became six
uh how long do you think before after
fans see the first episode people will
start asking about the musical being a
real thing
uh you mean like how how would i feel
about that or how i just i just like the
star the song and the sequence is so
good yeah i can like see fans being like
i'd go see that on broadway i would too
i'm hoping that this
i i look i'm very excited for it as well
too it was a lot of fun and um
and i hope fans yeah uh reacts to it in
a very positive way just as how we all
really enjoyed um you know working with
mark and and creating um uh uh that's um
that musical to come to life so we'll
we'll see
where it goes
yeah um one of the things that i really
enjoyed about the first two episodes is
it's like christmas time in the mcu um
can you sort of talk about being i think
it's the first mcu thing to really do
something like this so can you talk
about how that came about and what it
was like to make it well we wanted to
set this
story apart from falcon winter soldier
one division loki that has come out and
and you know any um
future shows um and one of the reasons
is setting it in the holidays season and
out of all the characters clint barton
made the most sense because he is one of
the few avengers with family um and
after the fallout of end game where he
lost his family uh became ronan and then
got his family back he's still dealing
with you know the lost time he's still a
deal he's still dealing with trying to
figure out like how can he make up for
all that and and which is why he is
making a big deal about spending time uh
during the holidays with them and of
course he gets stuck in a situation
where you know he has to figure out how
to get out of it in order to make it
back in time for for the holidays and
the big question is is he going to be
able to do so so um the holiday um
element is really important especially
with clint because he isn't ever he is a
family man and family it's all about the
holiday season it's about spending time
with the family so out of
you know all the properties this one
felt like it was the most fitting for
uh um something like this and other than
iron man 3 this will be the you know um
time that
we're doing this
i got to stop there i'm just going to
say congrats and i really can't wait to
watch the rest of the series thank you
you